we're very earth Tongji today earth
tones we called each other
yep um what you think miss works you
know that but what's this well that is
the Smith works mascot that is which is
me and it's got I don't know I don't
know how I'm supposed to talk about this
now because there's all kinds of legal
issues so I'm just going to so let's
toast though because tonight y'all is
the voice finale it looks disgusting but
it means pickling everyone knows I'm
gonna win I'm I'm just kidding here you
go okay I will say most times drinking
with you it doesn't end well for me but
it's mine um it's awesome so you can't
know this show would be so much better
if I could tell some of the crap that
you've they just dream just think about
what could happen that's it wait a
minute what are we toasting to the
finale are the two to Jake and Ricky yes
and I gotta say though I'm amazed that
jake has made it that far with the worst
coach in the history of
speaking of drinking there's so many
jobs like myself and you have is it
three restaurants right now and you're
opening a fourth there is uh so there's
a no red and in Tishomingo mm-hmm
because it's why is there one there
because that's that's kind of where I
live
yeah and then that's why yeah and then
there's one in Nashville and then
there's one in Gatlinburg and then we're
about to open one in Orlando and there's
others in the open because of all the
stuff to do that there's way smarter
people than me that decide where those
things go clearly really did you choose
Tishomingo I can't believe you did a
shot of vodka I can already tell you're
starting to actually I told him I said
there's no way she's gonna actually do a
shot of vodka I know I'm did tequila
why did tequila with Nick I've done the
shows I've done Rosie with Chrissy Oh is
John's I drink a shot of Rosie no but I
drank I drank yeah I drink on that this
show is fun hey no in all seriousness
with God's country he 1cm a single of
the year right
[Applause]
for Grammy you have like I know like
50,000 number ones but this was this
your biggest one God's country was that
the biggest sin no you never know until
a couple years later when you get past
it you look back you know but it just
it's got to be I mean that's what that
was a big record you know and for me to
get nominated for a Grammy and they hate
me at the Grammys so for them to be like
oh my god just nominating just put him
in there it's fine no I can't I can't
believe because you told me this one
time and I found this shocking because
you're so like even outside people that
aren't into country music everyone knows
you and everyone knows your music even
if they don't listen country regularly
like you're just so massive you're like
beyond country but anyway my favorite
album of yours I know this one's real
popular but my favorites stole your
second one let me show everyone why this
is my favorite one yes
come on
I mean what it
look fear stare and all that hair I do
have a surprise for you though and I was
excited to be able to do this for you
but else will you come on out of here
[Applause]
black in honor of God's country
something more than 2 million copies
y'all that's amazing I talked about
playlists a lot because it's full of
randomest I like his playlists like I'm
the first time we hung out I know I've
said this story before I was so shocked
I was like is this Duran Duran I was
like wow like you have like the most
random playlist so it you're totally
country obviously but you have like a
pretty broad everything yeah you have a
really broad playlist so to find out why
Blake loves some of those random songs
we came up with a little game because I
know he loves games called I just bring
my friends here and make them do stuff
they don't want to do it's called
celebrity playlist shuffle alright so
here's some works okay I hit this button
is this the same piece of crap do you
want to offer some money or be a sponsor
for this soon it's the first season is
this on the world television right this
is a big show can you get renewed for
another season we did but we don't have
them in again where's the herb I brought
you some you brought me a gift
that's kind yes okay what is it yes l
can you please bring this is
embarrassing I come to help them come
when I sleep
Oh
[Applause]
this is the new and improved Kelly
Clarkson stupid game
whatever game that year that you make
your friends play lights up as long as
you have to be uncomfortable on this
show playing your weird games now you
actually have locking nice podium this
guy look here rearview mirrors you do
that deal where you know like a soldier
is gonna surprise a family member but it
doesn't work because the kids like oh my
god there's that don't work now holders
I like that like beer pong my favorite
because every time you use this I want
people to know okay so wait you see on
this side okay okay you go on this side
okay thank you for my guests you're
welcome for like every episode you're
tossing it okay alright here's how it
works people thank you for this
beautiful you're welcome
I built it um you're amazing I wire I
had this button art okay so if I hit
this button our super computer shuffles
through Blake's playlist lands on a song
a Blake tells us what that song means
you know I to win or anything like what
no we just it's more like a game of like
figuring like getting inside why you
have this song in your playlist cuz most
people wouldn't expect some of this like
your games are awful you win it's a
Percy no you did play game on the show
and I did win alright here we go we're
gonna go there we go
okay who escaped the Pina Colada song
what a minute is that your song or my
song that's yours
that's my cuz I have that on my playlist
I know this is your plan okay what do I
win why do you know that song in your
playlist I have that on my like playlist
because when we go out to the lake and
there's a bunch of weird you know random
songs like that you have I'm on a boat
you know that song Brandon Brandon loves
that song you see it one time you know
okay I got it it was funny but I can't
imagine listening to that over and
drinking it's still funny really gonna
go again what a minute
cuz it's just my soul my life Billy Joel
yes you have to tell me it's your
playlist I thought we were a lot going
on me about you yes no it's your abuela
oh okay I thought we were doing the back
and forth yeah what it Billy well that's
okay I have that on there because it
reminds me when I was a kid there was a
television show called bosom buddies
that was a theme song to bosom buddy
which I'm sure it was probably a hit
song besides that eastbound and down oh
that needs to be a show Jerry Reed did
you ever see a span of down that TV show
it's funny Oh how do you that's from
Smokey and the Bandit remember the
movies I loved him with the mustache
yeah no no I'm thinking Tom Stoke that
was I liked him home so I know I know
I'm thinking I know it's Burt Reynolds I
was thinking of Tom Selleck how does
anybody get a word in on your show how
do they might get a word in you have a
talk show that you talk on
exactly okay so why do you like that
song I was just one of my all-time
favorites it reminds me of that movie
smoking that love gonna be yeah cool
Trans Am on their birth panels Burt
Reynolds thinking and then I thought oh
it's Tom Selleck yeah yeah that's why I
singing my headphones messages we have
to take a break oh thank god please if
there's any advertisers left for the
show please run your commercial for
Kelly I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this